angers corps chanter ma petite chanson
pour marine l'appelle la prêtresse était
allé à l'opéra avec ma petite chanson
avait l'air d'un con ma mère avec ma
petite chanson j'avais l'air d'un con
quand j'ai couru porter mon pool motarde
à marinette l'appelle la traîtresse
avait déjà fini tinée avec mon petit pot
jamais l'air d'un coup ma mère avec mon
petit pot j'avais l'air d'un con
quand je free pourrait traîne une
bicyclette à marinette label la
traîtresse avait acheté une auto avec
mon petit vélo j'avais l'air d'un con ma
mère avec mon petit vélo j'avais l'air
d'un coup quand j'ai couru tout chose au
rendez-vous de marine est labellisé
stade de reims un type qui l'embrassait
avec mon bouquet de fleurs j'avais l'air
d'un con ma mère avec mon bouquet de
fleurs j'avais l'air d'un con quand j'ai
couru brûlé la petite cervelle à
marinette l'appel étaient déjà morts de
la rue mme mal placée avec mon revolver
j'avais l'air d'un co ma mère avec mon
revolver j'avais l'air d'un coup quand
j'ai couru lugubre enterrement de
marinette label la traîtresse était déjà
ressuscité avec ma petite couronne où
j'avais même le conte ma mère avec ma
petite couronne j'avais le bon prix